i'm joined by health secretary sajid
javed good morning health secretary um
what do we know this morning about the
spread
of omicron uh infections and crucially
hospitalizations
well ever since we've learned about this
variant our strategy has been clear to
to buy time to time to assess it and
time to build our defenses
we're learning more about omicron all
the time but the truth is we still don't
know uh enough and that there's a gaps
in the in the data uh that we have uh
there there are significant
uncertainties as we look ahead but we
must work with the data that we've got
and not let the perfect be the enemy of
the good so
let me just share with you very quickly
what we do know
first of all we know that omicron
spreads very very quickly we can all see
the rising case numbers but we know that
there are many more people behind those
case numbers that are infected because
not everyone is is taking a test or
there's always a delay in the in in
getting test results and so
the actual number of infections would be
significantly higher than what case
numbers suggest and we know that case
numbers are and infections are doubling
at around
two to three times every two to three
days and that's observed data here in
the uk from south africa from
netherlands denmark that's observed data
of omicron the second thing we do know
is around vaccines so we know that your
two vaccines are sadly not enough to
protect you against symptomatic disease
but three vaccines are three vaccines
are excellent in the protection they
provide that's why we've focused very
heavily on our booster program in the
last few weeks i'm pleased to say that
in the last week in england we've seen
four million boost over four million
boosts we've seen new records being hit
every day i'm told that yesterday was a
new record day uh as well and and so
that that is a a very high level of
protection we can build on but the third
thing that we don't know enough about
and this is important trevor is that so
we know about the spread we know about
the vaccines but we don't know of enough
about the severity of uh omicron and so
there there is data from south africa
when you look at their hospitalization
rate versus delta that that
definitely suggests they got a lower
hospitalization rate but we don't know
whether if if that means the the virus
itself is intrinsically um you know less
severe or does it mean that south
africans have you know more uh more
protection through
your natural infection or vaccines or in
other ways so
and just the final point because if i if
i may is that with the severity that
even if it turns out to be less severe
and therefore a smaller percentage of
people are hospitalized here in the uk
than with delta a small percentage of a
large number of infections could still
mean a significant number of
hospitalizations okay that's a good
complete comprehensive picture just one
small detail um the reported number of
infections running something like 90 000
maybe 100 000 a day but you've just said
that you think actually that probably
means that
the actual level of infections is much
higher
we're being told that fracks for example
it could be as high as 300 000 what what
is the multiple to which you're working
right now if the official figure that
we're seeing is 90 000 what do you
really think it is well so let's to be
clear about this
the
you said report a number of affections
about nine thousand not infections
that's case numbers and the difference
between a case and an infection is a is
a cases are a subset of infections
that's where someone was feeling unwell
they've got a test and it's been
confirmed so the 90 000 by the way isn't
uh just omicron that is delta still
predominantly delta and with about the
a a significant degree of that being
omicron but infections what we already
know let me
perhaps i can better explain with delta
because we've got much more data on that
typically their case numbers represent
around a fifth or a quarter of total
infections at any one time and so with
omicron we know that the infections that
we sorry the cases that we're getting
the confirmed cases it will be a subset
of uh of total infections but because of
the the speed at which it's growing
doubling every two to three days the the
is likely to be an even smaller
proportion the cases of total infection
so it's hard to say with any kind of
certainty what's the total number of
infections but we know
from from all this data that they are
growing significantly in the community
so for example
we know from a test called esgene target
failure which is basically a proxy test
for omicron it's a lot quicker doing
that than the sequencing we know that
it's currently running at around 60
of all cases uh or new cases in england
overall okay so in fact we could see be
seeing a level of omicron infection
which is more than five times the
numbers that we case numbers at work
that we are seeing reported uh let me
ask you about another specific issue
what do we know about the proportion of
people who are remain unvaccinated
well we know first of all in terms of
numbers uh about 88 of the population
over the age of 12 have taken at least
one vaccine and 80 percent have taken
two over half the people of adult adults
are are now boosted so that's really
good in terms of your great set of
numbers especially the boosters the
biggest booster program in europe
there's about let's say around 10 of the
population that remain under vaccinated
and we know in hospital when you look at
hospitalizations they make up a
disproportionate amount of of those that
are severely ill in fact if we look at
those that are the the most ill in
hospital needing the most care and
attention around nine out of ten of them
are unvaccinated if i can say trevor
because it's a really important issue
that
people have had over a year almost a
year now to get vaccinated there's still
10 percent of our population that have
chosen for whatever reason not to get
vaccinated
adults yeah 5 million plus and
and i just cannot emphasize enough the
impact that they are having on the rest
of society they must really think about
the damage they are doing to society by
they take up hospital beds that could
have been used for someone with maybe a
heart problem or maybe someone who's
waiting for their elective surgery but
instead of protecting themselves and
protecting their community they choose
not to get vaccinated they are really
having a damaging impact and and i just
can't stress enough please do come
forward and get vaccinated it's a really
positive thing to do not just for
yourself for your loved ones but for
your community too i am i've dwelt at
some length on the numbers because
this is at the heart of the dispute
dispute that's brewing amongst your
parliamentary colleagues you suggested
for example at the beginning of this
week that um we could be up to 200 000
cases a day infections infections a day
the trends don't necessarily as we
understand the data suggests that that's
quite where we are
some of your colleagues think that
you're overstating the data in order to
allow you to bring in more restrictions
on the population
well in fact we would the data we use is
the data as it's being uh observed so we
know case numbers we understand a lot
more about covid and and infections over
the last couple of years a lot of
data has been built up we globally you
know through scientists around the world
they understand a lot more about that it
is true however that you can't be
certain about everything especially with
a new varied we can see already in the
community how quickly this is growing
but when when analysis is done so for
example the the the sage committee of
scientists that advice government have
just published uh what they view as
their as their latest assessment of the
situation uh that
they've given an analysis and as
ministers of course we will look at that
analysis but we can't just sort of
simply accept it as you know that is the
fact and that is definitely what's going
to happen as ministers we do have to
challenge it we have to
look at some of the underlying
assumptions and and challenge on those
and also as ministers when we make
decisions on the data that we are
presented with of course we have to
think you're broader than than just the
the epidemiological situation and have
to think about that any any action that
we take the impact that it might have on
people's life chances on businesses on
children so ministers jobs is
a much broader view but before we get to
that what um your critics would say is
that you get properly presented with a
range of scenarios by your scientific
advisors and what i think many would be
saying is that
you choose
the scenario to which you are responding
and invariably that's turning out to be
the most pessimistic so for example you
yourself have just said that the
emerging evidence from south africa is
that this might be
omicron might be less severe it might be
than we might be but you've chosen
to treat to act as though it is at least
as severe as delta so that you
are actually choosing the evidence to
which you're responding rather than
looking at the range of evidence you're
being offered by scientists no trevor
family i don't think that's the case at
all and let me explain is that we it
would be com it would be wrong
absolutely wrong for government to just
to say look we think this is as severe
and that's how we're going to behave
because we don't know there's a lot of
uncertainty around omicron and we have
to accept that there are gaps in the
data as i've said but we have to use the
data that we've got the data that we do
have is around how fast it is growing
the data about the vaccines
health secretary is the data you asked
for graham medley
let me just put this to you the graham
medley who's the chairman of the sage
modeling committee told the spectator
yesterday we generally model what we are
asked to model there is a dialogue in
which policy teams discuss with the
modelers what they need to inform their
policy what is that supposed to mean if
it doesn't mean that they're giving you
the evidence that you want i think what
it means is that
they as in this case i think he must be
referring to sage which are the
government's sort of uh scientific
advisers is that what they are modeling
is the question they would have been
asked broadly put is taking into account
all the
the data you have both from the uk and
abroad on this new variant where do you
think it's heading i think that's the
broad question and they inevitably and
perfectly understandably would come up
with a number of assumptions that they
would make but as i've said our job as
ministers then is to obviously to look
at that report it is very sobering when
when you look at it but to to look at it
and then to to challenge to sensibly
challenge underlying assumptions but if
the report only tells you what you want
to hear
there's not much challenge involved
there isn't it well it's not it's not i
mean he's telling he's saying that we
tell the government the things that it's
asking us for we're not telling them the
things that
other things that we might know but
they're not asking in the sense i think
what he means is that
asking in the sense that the the the
government's request is tell us what you
think the the data suggests about where
this thing is heading it is you know if
it was something that i was asking for
of course what i'd be asking if if it i
went who would want to ask for an
outcome uh like the one that they're
suddenly currently presenting my job is
to is to challenge that and and that is
what the government is doing and i think
it's the appropriate thing to do you
know there are some people uh
there's some people out there that think
that that lock down is the answer uh to
any any need let's come to the face
there are others that think that you
shouldn't do anything at all and my my
job the government's job is actually to
to look at the data to get the best
assessment we possibly can and actually
all right let's come to what you
actually have to do um
you are almost going to have to ask
people to undertake or endure new
restrictions and it's being um
reported that there is a plan are there
plans being drawn up for a circuit
breaker locked down after christmas i'm
not asking you whether you've decided on
that or not though you can tell me but
is it true that those plans are being
drawn up
we've taken measures already i took the
the plan b measures through parliament
this week which i didn't enjoy doing one
bit at all i didn't come into to
government to to restrict freedoms of
people but i think people understand you
know why we we are
presented that action to parliament and
and we keep the situation under review
of course we will assess the report the
recent report will be given by sage we
will challenge certain assumptions and
we'll come to a government decision but
but can i say we are entering uh this
phase of this pandemic in a very strong
position and the reason for that strong
position is because we opened up in the
summer we have the best vaccination
program in europe especially our booster
program we have new treatments that
didn't exist before including
antibiotics and we have a fantastic
testing i'm not interrupting you for the
sake of it but we've had this
conversation before and
viewers have heard that um just to be
clear in your last sentence are you
telling me that you've actually had uh a
suggestion from sage that they should be
further locked down no the suggestion
we've had from sage is the one that
they've published it's in their minute
it's public so there's their suggestions
i think are quite clear uh there but as
i say as as government you know we are
advised by scientists but it's
ultimately that ministers uh will make a
decision and when we make a decision
there's a number of factors that we need
to take into account if as we are
hearing from scientists and from the bma
that the numbers are suggesting that
they should be further locked down will
the government be prepared to uh
undertake that
we we've shown in the past as government
in dealing with this pandemic that we
will do what is what is necessary but
it's got to be backed up by the data and
as i say we are very if the data
suggests that unless you act now as some
scientists are saying and you've already
said the doubling numbers are dramatic
every day counts if the numbers suggest
that we should have further restrictions
will you be ready to do that we are
watching the data discussing it with our
scientists and our best advisors almost
on an hourly basis and and we will
monitor that very carefully we will keep
the situation in the review but i i
can't stress it of how
the situation today in terms of our
defenses is very different you started
your program today by comparing it to
christmas last year one big difference
christmas last year are the vaccinations
the antivirals the other treatments our
testing systems and the fact that we
opened up in the summer in the way that
we did and if you did have to take some
new measures would you recall parliament
to approve those measures look if and
it's an if
the the prime minister's already been
cleared to parliamentarians if there was
a need to take any further action we
would recall parliament and it would
have to be a decision for parliament
that is only right and proper
let's talk about the politics um
lord frost went last night um
did you know that was going to happen
and do you understand his reasons for
leaving
i didn't know it's going to happen and i
do understand his reasons and let me
just say this first about lord frost
i've had the privilege of working with
him now for a couple of years i think
he's an outstanding public servant and i
think that you know the way brexit was
done and how we achieved that and
achieved those successes
he's been a central architect of that so
i wish him the best but i do understand
his reasons he's a principled man you
know principal people do resign from the
government i know all about that and uh
and that's something uh as a decision
for him to take but it's pretty
catastrophic isn't it uh half of your
benches voted against you during the
week uh you lost and not uh in uh north
shropshire uh
what is undesirable undeniable is that
uh the magic of boris johnson has gone
last time we spoke about this um i i
asked
you and i've in fact asked mr zahawi uh
last week whether um boris johnson was
still uh the election winner when we
spoke you said one word yes are you
still prepared to say yes
yeah i think boris johnson
i think i think boyce johnson is the
best person to take us through the
challenge that's not the same thing as
saying he's an electric winner yeah what
he what he we've had
we've had one very disappointing
election result and from that you cannot
take away the ability for of boris
johnson to win election after election
remember just a couple of weeks ago we
had a by-election victory as well so
this
don't get me wrong i think the north
structural result was a very
disappointing result we have to learn
lessons from it we especially have to
listen to the people of north shropshire
and i hope that at the next election we
can win that seat back but when you're
asking me about boris johnson remember
it is boris johnson that made the
decisions around the pandemic to to keep
britain out of the european medical
agency for example which meant that we
had the biggest and the best vaccination
program in europe to buy antivirals to
open up in the summer it's the same
boris johnson that is taking us through
this pandemic okay well here is what the
people of north shropshire said to that
same boris johnson with their vote which
is
after barnard castle after the christmas
parties after pretty much everything
else we're hearing out of whitehall
same question i asked your colleagues
more than once this year
why should we when we obey the rules and
you flank them
why should we pay the blindest bit of
attention to what you tell us to do mr
health secretary when you say we need to
tackle omicron you know i i understand
that and uh i i absolutely understand
where those kinds of questions might
come from and that's why i think it is
really really important that we maintain
public confidence by having that
investigation that is now taking place
right sue gray is carrying out this
investigation and that will establish
the fact
that you pay and who owes her job to you
shouldn't it be led by somebody
independent well i
i i think that's not
yeah i know this isn't your intention
but i don't think that's very respectful
to to sue grey in there no no she is a
disrespectful she's a she's a senior
civil servant
uh that that is uh someone who is is
known for her neutrality and uh her
probity and i think
having having a senior civil servant
that is not a minister not a politician
carry out investigation that's not
unusual
that's exactly the sort of whitehall
answer that makes people feel cynical
that of course you would say that but
actually the question is shouldn't
somebody independent do this and let me
just ask you because we're running out
of time let me just ask you
what this is really uh about
in scotland they've already moved to
tougher measures
and they're doing that with confidence
because people believe in that country
in uh their prime minister can you look
me in the face and say honestly
that you believe that england will be
equally compliant when asked to do
tougher things from a by a prime
minister who can't even impose
discipline on his own office
i i think i think people will uh if and
first of all
you're suggesting there are new measures
to take and let's just see what happens
as i say we keep the situation in the
review but if we do have to take further
measures
as as the situation develops if we have
to do that then i believe the british
people will respond in the same way they
have throughout this pandemic whereas
they understand the issues they know
just how important it is for them and
their families and and and they will
respond accordingly
health secretary thank you very much for
your time this morning thank you